[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events if you'd like to
see us on the road head on over to
theminimalists.com to find a city near
you or you can watch recordings of all
of our live events over at patreon.com
the minimalists enjoy um so first i want
to thank you for both uh directly and
indirectly empowering me to leave an
unfulfilling job and yeah
yeah thank you thank you thank you
what's your name
oh sorry my name is crystalline hey
crystalline what's on your mind
yeah um i
i've become a completely different
person since i started living
in accordance with my values which is
wild imagine
um
but yes so thank you thank you for that
i um i my mental health has
significantly improved and
i feel like i am serving a purpose and
that's that's really a big a big thing
for me
um so my question for you is related to
mental health actually
um so even though i know what my values
are at my core i sometimes find myself
going through periods where it is
difficult to continue to hold myself
accountable to living in accordance with
those values
i know that being hard on myself doesn't
solve anything um and i'm not looking
for a prescription but i would love to
hear more about how you each work to
keep yourselves living intentionally and
specifically when your brain is trying
to do otherwise
give me an example
um
so
i have adhd
and that can make me pretty impulsive
sometimes and i don't want to be
impulsive and i know that i don't want
to be impulsive
but sometimes it can still be a little
hard to fight that
yeah i have ocd and so i can be quite
obsessive sometimes
last night we finished the orlando event
and it was it went great everyone seemed
to love it except me
and
i will
often tell myself stories that aren't
true
and we were just talking about this on
the drive up actually and i noticed this
isn't a prescription so i'm not telling
you to do it but i've noticed that
something has arisen in me in the last
two years well last year and a half
really
um
that
has totally eviscerated a lot of the
self-doubt
and
whenever i start to get into these sort
of obsessive self-doubt spirals
i literally laugh out loud
uncontrollably at it i can't help it
because i see it for what it is i see
the absurdity which is also what emil
was talking about the philosopher we
talked about
the absurdity of the universe basically
it's all absurd when you look at it and
we take these things so freaking
seriously and that's what this downward
spiral happens for me with these
negative thoughts and i i whenever i
catch myself looking at that i just
laugh
and it instantly i just
it evaporates and it comes back and i
just laugh at it again
because it's all absurd
you know um there's a certain
there's a certain benefit in looking at
our various moods as kind of like the
seasons you know where summer days are
are really exciting in a way that winter
days may not be and both of those days
may be kind of tolerable in a way that
rainy days might not be but because we
sort of accept that as part of the
nature of reality because we don't
look at the universe as you know
expressing its mood you know and it's
we're going to have a sunny day in the
middle of december in chicago we don't
expect that right like we accept it as
part of the cycles of nature
we we plan around those things and we
say okay it's winter i'm gonna go skiing
i'm gonna go sledding hey it's rainy i
can't do a picnic today wish i could but
i can't do a picnic today that's cool
i'm gonna take out an umbrella i'm gonna
wear a hoodie i'm gonna stay inside have
some hot cider or something like that we
know what tk does when it rains it's
it's really hot out today like ah maybe
i'll go to the beach and we plan around
it right
i think
we can do that with ourselves as well
because our feelings are kind of like
the seasons they move in cycles and it's
very easy to view feelings of irritation
feelings of unhappiness feelings of low
motivation as some sort of evidence
against yourself as some sort of sign
that you're doing something wrong and i
would encourage you to look at those as
like rainy days or like snowy days it's
not a sign that i'm doing something
wrong it's a sign that i'm a
multi-dimensional human being who
requires the full range of my emotional
spectrum in order to be alive
and that's why there is so much
great art and there's so
many great expressions of creativity
that come from these different states
you do not get all of the great love
songs and all the great movies if you
are just one dimensional in the way you
feel you don't get that from a state of
yeah i feel motivated all the time and
this is like the level that i'm always
at or if you're just winning all the
time winning all the time someone who's
winning all the time does not write a
great memoir look at all the sports
biographies they're the most vapid books
when you read the books about winners
well here's what i did and then after i
won that tournament i went on and i
decided to win the next one
it's like what the hell am i going to
learn from that right yeah there's never
any rain or snow it's always sunny and
perfect
and um of course our internal state
there's
there are weather are certain weather
patterns there i think that's a
beautiful analogy yeah can i say one
more thing about it of course yeah
i don't think the goal is to be happy or
motivated i think the goal is to be
emotionally versatile to live in a state
of harmony with all of your different
feelings regardless of what they are and
so think of it as a kind of
psychological choreography when um when
music is playing and you're at a wedding
right and they play some song like ymca
or i got a feeling or happy by pharrell
you're not lost right because those
kinds of songs are really easy to dance
to all you gotta do is just move your
body and whatever you do is gonna be
right
but suppose the dj just switches it up
and plays something like jazz or plays
something like polka it's easier to feel
awkward easier to feel uncomfortable and
i think happiness and motivation those
are like genres of music that are easy
to dance to which is why when we feel
good we don't call up our friends being
like man i'm so confused i don't know
what to do i just feel so amazing right
now
but we do that when we feel jealous when
we feel angry when we feel sad we're
confused because we don't know how to
dance to that
and and that doesn't mean that something
is wrong with us it just means that this
is a genre of music that requires a
different kind of coordination and it's
an art unto itself and you got to learn
to dance with jealousy you got to learn
to dance with sadness you got to learn
to dance with anger but all of those
emotions
are your friends and they can take you
some to very interesting places so i
would say
be present to your different filling
states at these various times
and develop a plan for being intentional
and saying okay when i feel this way
instead of resisting that feeling and
fighting against it and trying to make
myself feel a better emotion
i'm going to
learn how to dance to that by observing
what sorts of activities do i have an
easier time grooving with when i feel
that way this may be a time for me to
write this may be a time for me to call
a loved one this may be a time for me to
take some self-care and lay back and do
something mellow like meditate this may
be a time for me to increase my exercise
this may be a time for me to do
whatever it is you have an easy time
grooving to
yeah
the power of observation
that was awesome
well it makes me like the bit the answer
to something like uh
observation is
more powerful than acting in in some
cases right yeah especially with these
emotions so i'm adh28
you can get you got here's add type two
right no i am adhd as well
um that is why i will have two thoughts
in my head and then one is just like see
it
um
so i i totally get those impulses but
i'm just curious tell me one of the
impulses that like you find yourself
beating yourself up over oh
um
so like
when i when i say like impulsive i mean
like self-medicating with caffeine or
like doing things that like i know will
make me feel better temporarily but then
like all that caffeine leads to anxiety
and like bad things and
like you know not great things yeah no i
yeah i totally get that you know i have
this
i mean
i get disagreed with a lot on this but i
feel like we're all addicted to
something
and you know choose your addictions
carefully that's what i'll say that's my
pithy answer
i like that i like that a lot thank you
one more quick thing yeah
i'm so sorry i know they're gonna kick
us out
but look i i
i think temptation is just an attractive
opportunity to meet a legitimate need in
perhaps an unhealthy way
but the thing you've got to do when you
experience temptation is not fall into
that trap of being like oh my gosh this
is evidence that i'm evil how disgusting
of me to want coffee when i know that i
shouldn't want it you've got to validate
that temptation and say i would not
crave this unless there was a legitimate
need for something that is okay for me
to have and it turns out that based on
my habits and based on my knowledge and
based on my experience i'm limited to
thinking that coffee is the thing that's
gonna do it and it is gonna do it but
it's also gonna bring along some baggage
that i don't want so the goal isn't to
just resist the thing that we shouldn't
do you've got to find something that
truly meets that need in a healthy way
because the need is legitimate even if
the way of going about it is
self-detrimental so what are some ways
you can explore the possibility for
satisfying whatever that craving is
during those moments of self-medicating
don't fall into a lifestyle of just
trying not to do the wrong thing there's
a verse in the bible for this by the way
it says do not be overcome with evil but
overcome evil with good
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free